we're revealing the best books of the
year so far
according to amazon books and it's a
great list
coming in at number three all my rage by
uh sabbata here
number two
is what my bones know a memoir of
healing from complex trauma it's a long
one it's by stephanie foo
and
the number one pick for the best book of
the year so far is
remarkably bright creatures a novel by
shelby van pelt
all such mouthfuls we're joined by
amazon books editor director sarah
gellman good morning thanks for joining
we all want to know how you come about
picking these these great books so so
what comes into the decision making well
i feel like my job is pretty great and i
lead a team of editors whose job it is
to read books we read hundreds every
year and it's all to hand curate books
that we love for customers on amazon so
this list is our favorite books that
were published between january and june
of this year
so what about the the top list the top
top of the list the best book of the
year why did you come up with this trick
it's so good so it's remarkably bright
creatures it is a mouthful by shelby van
pelt another mouthful this is a debut
novel okay and it's just a book that my
whole team fell in love with men and
women so it's really a book for everyone
and it's a story about an unlikely
friendship between a widow and an
octopus but stay with me that was a
threat that was the same yeah i know it
sounds a little strange but it's really
about aging it's about finding love
rediscovering family and at its core is
a mystery and this octopus is like key
to solving the mystery wow and for you
know i read a lot very layered yeah i
know i like layers i do like layers yeah
it's hard to describe but i read so much
and to me this book was totally original
and it's a book that you read and then
you miss the characters like i want to
go back
and see them again oh yeah uh so all my
rage you say he's got crossover appeal
it's number three on the list tell us
about that and also tell us is this a
dictatorship or a democracy or like this
is the sarah gilman
these are the team picks this is not a
democracy it is a democracy
[Laughter]
it is
it always reminds me of that cheer movie
bring it on
um no so this is all my rage by sabata
here and this book actually it's a young
adult and i read it and did not realize
that it was for young adults i read it
as an adult novel so it is for all ages
and the author is actually the author of
a best-selling young adult fantasy
series called an ember in the ashes this
is her first contemporary novel and it's
about two star-crossed pakistani
teenagers in a desert town in california
so i read this on an airplane and the
woman next to me is watching a comedy
and she's like cracking up and i was
like
it's very sad but it's beautifully
written it's really thought-provoking
it's just really raw so for a lot of us
actually i bought my father's day gift
yesterday okay
but you say number five's a great it's
father's day great father's day gift um
if my fathers are watching this is what
they're getting um river of gods by
candace millard so this is narrative
nonfiction it's about the search for the
source of the nile in the 19th century
and what i love about this book
yeah now if you like history
world war ii
the thing that i like about this book
and that's interesting is that millard
actually confronts colonialism in a way
that a lot of historians do not so she's
telling the story of these two european
men they are just like single-mindedly
trying to make these geographic
discoveries but she also talks about
this formerly enslaved man named cd
bombay and really he's the true hero of
the story and this book inspired a lot
of healthy debate on my team um and yes
it did
okay talking about the colonialism piece
of it actually
because this is a this is an age-old
story matthew perry it's his story it's
in number it's the people
climbing everest yeah
it's she handles it really really well
she does and it as you said it's a great
father's day gift i refuse to become my
parents i don't i'm being stereotyped as
a father here i want remarkably bright
creatures the novel about the octopus
okay so but there's there's everything
about it very woman who's a chemist
i love all this is so good okay i love
this book lessons in chemistry by bonnie
garmas so this book to me is like a
cross between john irving and also maria
semple who wrote where did you go
bernadette and it's a story about a
female chemist in the 1960s it's a novel
and she's brilliant but she's stunted in
her career because of all the sexism she
faces so she becomes a very unlikely
host of a cooking show and to her
cooking is chemistry it's science and
she ends up teaching all of these 1960s
housewives about a lot more than cooking
a lot more than how to make a meatloaf
it's really a female empowerment story
and someone on my team that said this is
her new favorite book of all time yeah
well baking is all about chemistry yeah
exactly really is measure i am so bad at
it absolutely you make such good tv
about helping people not watch tv and
read
it's really great here's my relationship
advice love your significant other like
sarah gilman loves books
there it is yeah
we love you man's playing it for us
sarah gellman thank you so much thanks
so much to see the full list of amazon's
best books of the year so far head to
cbs mornings on twitter facebook or
instagram